this would be the third and final video
in this sequence on nietzsche's great
work the genealogy of morals but i've
decided that i'm going to deviate from
my plan of originally doing three videos
each one focused just on one of the
essays
and for this this third essay i think
that it actually requires two videos
because there's so much material there
and there is a kind of natural linchpin
joining point about halfway through
so we're going to focus on this one on
the first part
but before we do that
there's a few things that i want to
actually touch on a few things i
actually want to hit on
that are coming a little bit later on in
the
third essay of the genealogy
in part because it tells us where we're
going where we're headed so
one of these is actually the very last
section section 28
and
nietzsche is saying something there that
is really striking
that
should
really
challenge you if you're thinking in
terms of this this distinction between
you know a morality of good and bad
that's imposed by the powerful the
strong
and then a morality
of evil and good that that comes up from
the slave revolt and morality
so here's the passage
he says
apart from the ascetic ideal
man the human animal
had no meaning so far
that's pretty important this whole
chapter this whole section this whole
essay is about the ascetic ideal
and the ascetic ideal is not something
that the warrior the strong the blonde
beast the barbarian coming in from the
outside and imposing
their rule on others
the
superman you know if we're projecting
ahead into the future
that's not something characteristic of
them the ascetic ideal that's something
that's actually characteristic of
the figure that we're going to call the
priest we saw
earlier in
the first essay and now we're going to
explore in much greater detail and of
the herd or the mass or the ordinary
person
this aesthetic ideal asceticism
is where you are foregoing deliberately
foregoing certain things that you would
ordinarily indulge yourself in because
your desires point you towards them so
it's a saying no to desires
asceticism
is often directed against desires for
food you know for fasting for example
desires for drink desires for sex
desires for stimulation
really anything that you can say no to
there can be an ascetic
commitment an ascetic element so
nietzsche is saying apart from the
ascetic ideal
not just the mere aesthetic practices
but apart from the aesthetic ideal man
the human animal had no meaning so far
his existence on earth contained no goal
why man at all was a question without an
answer the will for man and earth was
lacking behind every great human destiny
there sounded a refrain as a yet greater
in vain
this is precisely what the ascetic ideal
means that something was lacking
that man was surrounded by a fearful
void
he did not know how to justify to
account for to affirm himself he
suffered from the problem of his meaning
he also suffered otherwise
he was in the mane a sickly animal but
his problem was not suffering itself but
that there was no answer to the crying
question why do i suffer
now
we want to be careful with this not to
read this into nietzsche's understanding
of the strong we're fairly
straightforward and in certain respects
um
simple and and almost you might say
innocent in a certain respect not
innocent that they don't do anything bad
right but innocent in the sense that
they're not infected with a kind of
sickness that that he's talking about
they do things they impose rule they get
engaged in combats they rival with each
other
they defend their societies they expand
their societies they strive for posts
and positions
and they
reward friends
make new friends they fight enemies
but they don't ask themselves the
question
why
in a fundamental way
that comes on the scene nietzsche thinks
when suffering comes on the scene
when and that can happen for a warrior
you know you could think of ajax for
example who really got a raw deal
if you read you know
the uh the iliad and the odyssey
and you look at um
the play of the ajax as well
ajax was one of the great warriors of
greece who fought against troy
a rival to odysseus
and um
something bad happens to him actually
he
uh intends to kill odysseus at one point
and athena comes in and sort of steals
his mind and then renders him insane so
he actually rounds up some sheep
and
slaughters them
tortures one that he thinks is odysseus
and then she puts his mind back in him
he realizes what he's done that what
he's done is incredibly you know silly
shameful stupid
and that now he's sort of a
an object for mockery and he kills
himself
ajax could be said perhaps to have you
know be prefiguring this why
what is the point of all of this
um
in a way but certainly not in the way
that nietzsche talks about with the
priest and the ascetic ideal
doing so
later on so that's where we're headed
the other thing which is kind of a
linchpin between the two
main parts of the third essay
and you notice i've got all this stuff
on the board about the warrior the
priest and the herd
what we're dealing with there
are
sections
there we go sections
13 14 and 15. and i'm not going to go
into complete detail on all these the
next video will
hit on them
a lot more closely
but i just want to bring this up in part
because it helps to to read that back
into the previous sections so that you
understand where we're going why he's
talking about philosophers in the novels
and shifts to priests when actually the
priests are in some respects prior to to
the philosophers
so um
why do i have this schema up here and
why are there three parts to it before
we were talking about
master morality and slave morality you
know good versus bad
where the good impose their rule on the
bad they get to define the good as
themselves against the the bad where the
calm and the vulgar the powerless
and then evil versus good where the the
weak define the the powerful as as evil
and then define themselves in retrospect
as good that's a binary scheme right so
why do we have a tripartite scheme here
why do we have
three different figures i mean it's
obviously we can identify the herd with
the
herd morality with the
trans valuation of values you know good
versus evil
obviously we can identify the warrior
with this original set of valuations
that nietzsche thinks you know it took
place beforehand the strong imposing
themselves as the good on the
on the weak um
what about this third figure then where
does he fit in
well that's that's what makes this book
so particularly interesting
the figure of the priest is really the
central figure of this book
i thought that when i first started
reading this
decades ago and started writing on it in
classes and i still think that's that's
the key to this book now so this figure
of of the priest
the warriors are pretty straightforward
they like i said you know they impose
their rule they impose a certain
evaluation on things they call
themselves those who are those who are
truthful they they despise the herd
they fight with each other they can
recognize uh other individuals worthy of
their dignity in each other they
exchange gifts with each other their
relations to each other are governed to
some degree by custom their relations to
those outside of the range are governed
by nothing and they will use whatever
force they decide to use upon upon those
people including upon the weak the herd
so the warriors are strong they are
noble
the herd
the people who are imposed upon
are weak and in this chapter we get to
they are also sick
they are infected with something and in
the last section
or in the last essay
the second essay
we saw the origin of the bad conscience
and part of the origin of the bad
conscience was this you know the urges
the life urges
vitality desire all these sort of things
hemmed in
and being said no to
by outside forces outside forces like
the state the ruler
religion
but also the individual sort of turning
this inward upon themselves and taking a
kind of delight in imposing a
no a tr a prohibition upon themselves
and tearing at themselves
and that's what's left to the weak to do
the herd the the mass
they are sick in that respect
now nietzsche thinks that the priest
originally is coming from the same upper
aristocratic class
as the warrior they're not coming from
the herd it's not as if the herd
you know produces its own champion
who you know rises out of their ranks
the way we have in all these movies
it's rather that there's already
somebody who's aristocratic but there's
something different about him
there's something
on the one hand
less vital
weaker
sicker less
able to to forget things to engage in
the combat to engage in the rivalry and
on the other hand
stronger
greater
more
able to engage in other things to bring
about something new
to
harness
forces
possibilities
dig out capabilities
work with ideas
that were previously available for the
warrior
and nietzsche doesn't really talk about
this but somebody who i would say
is kind of a bridge figure he's he
doesn't fit the the priest
in this sense
but he's kind of a bridge figure would
be very interesting to think about is
odysseus
the man of all all whiles
the one who uses um
thought to hem people in
now the priest does it in in other ways
and the priest is the one who produces
something new
he changes
or he produces
new things in in religion
we saw that the origins of religion for
nietzsche
lie
in a sort of
reverence or debt owed to the ancestors
and as the tribe or the community
becomes stronger the ancestors are you
know elevated they become even greater
figures with with more debt owed to them
but the priest is able to introduce
morality into this
and the priest is able to work with
moral concepts in a way that the warrior
is not in a way that actually hems in
the warrior in a way that has the risk
the danger
and the capability of making the warrior
actually
be humbled be shamed be
brought down be
reduced in value
so i'm going to go on now and let's look
at
section 13.
so he says
the ascetic
appears to represent life against life
it takes the instincts the urges the
desires the drive
of life and then it turns it against
itself so for instance fasting take
fasting as an example if you're fasting
because you are
trying to control your body you're
trying to control your appetites you're
trying to subjugate part of your will by
using your will
um
you're subjugating part of your life
force you're subjugating part of your
normal animal energies and and force and
drive towards that which is is
consumable
so it looks like it's life being turned
against itself right he says
physiologically considered and not
merely psychologically it's a simple
absurdity
but he says it can only be apparent it
must be a kind of provisional
formulation
an interpretation and psychological and
misunderstanding of something whose real
nature could not for a long time be
understood or described as it really was
the ascetic ideal nietzsche says
springs from the protective instinct of
a degenerating life
which tries by all means to sustain
itself and to fight for its existence so
you know when do you need to fast when
do you need to control your consumption
of food
there's really two main
reasons why this would be the case one
is you don't have enough food and if
you're going to survive you have to
learn self-discipline so you don't eat
everything all up at once the way you
know you know animals out in the wild
tend to eat up everything all at once
they don't tend to store things away for
later i know there are some animals that
do
but you know consider the ones that are
actually closer to us
like you know wolves when wolves go and
eat stuff they don't you know say
we need to reserve some of this this
feast for a while
let's leave a leg over here
they eat they eat as much as they can
well human beings are like that too
and even if you're in a society where
they do set aside food maybe they're not
going to give you that food so maybe you
need to control the amount that you
consume
maybe when it comes to
food there would be another reason for
doing that
by
fasting by controlling your intake of
food by not saying yes i need that over
there
you learn how to develop self-control
you know if you read
if you read the monastic fathers
gluttony is the very first vice that
they say has to be subjugated
and why well it's because it's in
certain ways the least serious of the
vices it's the least you know it's the
most
bodily and it's one that we deal with
every day whereas lust you know maybe
we don't actually deal with that every
day that's a bodily one as well but
gluttony we have to get control over not
only our consumption of food but our
desire
for consumption of food keep it within
certain limits hem it in
choose ourselves
what we're going to allow and what we're
not going to allow and if we can do that
then we actually have developed a
certain degree of self mastery
well that's the ascetic ideal at work
so he says an aesthetic ideal springs
the from the protective instinct of a
degenerating
a sick
although
vital but still sick
life which tries by all means to sustain
itself and to fight for its existence
it indicates a partial physiological
obstruction and exhaustion against which
the deepest instincts of life which have
remained intact the deepest instincts of
life being the will to power the will to
dominate the will to take in new to take
in things which are not oneself to
subjugate them to oneself to make them
part of what one is
like you said life is about
expropriation about exploitation of
other
things
so he says
the deepest instincts of life
continually struggle with new expedients
and devices the aesthetic ideal is such
an expedient so the ascetic ideal is one
way in which life
tries to further itself tries to
continue itself
so he says
life wrestles in it and through it with
death and against death the ascetic
ideal is an artifice for the
preservation of life
that this ideal acquired such power and
ruled over men as imperiously as we find
it in history
expresses a great fact the sickliness of
the type of man we have we have hitherto
or at least of the tamed man on the
physiological struggle of man against
death or more precisely not just a
physiological struggle against death but
a psychological struggle
against disgust with life because life
can become disgusting we can lose its
value it can lose its savior
against exhaustion
against the desire for the end
the ascetic priest is the as he says the
incarnate desire to be different
so originality real originality for
nietzsche is not coming
through the warrior it's coming
through the figure of
the priest the ascetic the one who
is
struggling in a way that the warrior
doesn't even understand
is not capable of doesn't find
themselves having to do
so he says
the ascetic priest is the incarnate
desire to be different to be in a
different place and indeed this desire
in its greatest extreme its distinctive
fervor and passion but precisely this
power of his desire nietzsche says
is the chain that holds him captive so
that he becomes a tool
he becomes
the door he becomes the way opening up
for something
yet greater than himself which is this
ascetic ideal which he embodies
which he uses
which only he truly knows
but which will outlast him as well
so he says it's precisely this power
that enables him to persuade to
existence the whole herd of the
ill-constituted
disgruntled underprivileged unfortunate
and all who suffer from themselves so
those who are the losers those who are
the the under
class or really all the other lower
classes those who are not in the ones
who get to call the shots and get to
determine what counts as value and what
what doesn't count as value
the priest is able to
as he says
persuade to existence to reveal to them
something new that's not coming
from the herd becoming aware of
themselves on their own and having an
awakening and then turning against the
upper classes it's a portion of the
upper classes in a way descending to the
lower
and using them as a tool against the
upper
that gives them their class
consciousness that gives them their
understanding of there's being something
better some other way that they can
struggle
how does he do that by instinctively
going before them as their shepherd
so he says you will see my point this
ascetic priest this apparent enemy of
life it's a mistake
to think of as the priest as merely the
enemy of life
as merely the representative
of the herd against the the warrior the
noble class the true bringers of value
or anything like that that's non nichia
that's a distorted read of nietzsche
what nietzsche is actually saying is the
priest
is the only apparent enemy of life this
denier
he is among
the greatest conserving and yes creating
forces of life
so this is a very important dynamic here
this is something that's going to be
running throughout
initiative
is really coming
from here
it's not coming from the herd
the herd can't produce anything truly
new
all they can do is take what's available
and change it modify it work with it
rework it
put it into new configurations that
favor them so for example you know
democratization for nietzsche you know
to go very far ahead in where we are
with this
democratization does not really take
place because the herd now conscious of
itself you know says wow we're going to
settle hash with these aristocrats and
we're not going to let them run things
nowadays would be something more like
the people versus you know those who
actually pull the power strings right
um nietzsche would say no
all they do is they take ideas they take
mechanisms that were already put into
play
basically by this the the priest the
ascetic the one who
has strength and uses it to benefit the
people to you know help them to lead
them to
bring out what is in them against the
the warrior
um and without that
the herd wouldn't be able to do very
much
so it's the interplay between the herd
and the priest
that brings about the the condition that
we're in today for nietzsche
the time essentially of resentment
so let's get back now
all that said
and let's ask about this question the
ascetic ideal
how does it take hold
what is it what is as he says what is
the meaning of aesthetic ideals
and he says well we need to think about
a lot of different people a lot of
different classes of
people who have ascetic
ideals i'm going to erase a bit because
we're going to need some of this board
for talking about all these different
kinds of people these different kinds of
classes who he is
putting forth and examining
and
among them
are the artists
says in the in the case of artists what
do ascetic ideals mean
nothing or too many things and we'll
come back to one of those uh in
particular in a moment
in the case of philosophers
and scholars
something like a sense an instinct for
the most favorable preconditions of
higher spirituality
in the case of women at best one more
seductive charm a touch of morbidity and
fair flesh the angelic look of a plump
pretty animal in the case of the
physiologically deformed and deranged
he says this is the majority of mortals
physiologically deformed and deranged
and attempt to see themselves as too
good for this world a saintly form of
debauch their chief weapon in the
struggle against slow pain and boredom
in the case of
priests
the distinctive priestly faith
their best instrument of power also the
supreme license for power
in the case of saints finally at pretext
for hibernation
they're novisima gloria cupido they're
reposed in nothingness their form of
madness so notice what he's saying here
the ascetic ideal
it's not just one single thing it takes
on different forms
in these different people these
different classes
priests philosophers saints
ordinary people artists
so he says
it's meant so many things to man
but it's an
expression of the basic fact of the
human will
it's what
it's horuvacuy it's
fear of a void of
not being full of
there not being meaning of not being
able to to provide oneself the answers
for things the aesthetic ideal is an
answer to a question the question of the
meaning of life
that gets raised and raised and raised
in so many different ways
and being an artist being a philosopher
being a priest being a saint being all
these different things
those are attempts in action to work out
what is the meaning of life
those who become philosophers
i can tell you this from experience
you don't become a philosopher because
you say this is the most rational thing
for me to do it's going to make me a lot
of money and make me famous
i don't know anybody who got into
philosophy for that reason and if you
did get into philosophy for that reason
you'd be an idiot to do so
i do know some people who you know want
to be artists because they want to have
an entourage and they want to be rich
and famous but
all you got to do is look at the lives
of most artists to figure out
that usually doesn't happen and
historically to be an artist was
actually not to be at the level that
we've placed the artist these days
all of these are ways to try to respond
to the question what is the meaning of
life what is the meaning of my life
and if your life doesn't have a meaning
or a goal
then you have to come up with one
so nature goes out and says what is the
meaning of ascetic ideals
let's take the case of an artist
take an individual case i've often been
asked about this is somebody who
nietzsche had interaction with and at
one time really seemed to love and that
later on turned against
richard wagner
what does it mean for for example when
an artist like richard wagner pays
homage to chastity in his old age
what's he asking about there
well you know when wagner was younger
not only wagner but his music in general
had kind of a reputation
for awakening the erotic
for awakening sexuality
and
for nietzsche that's seen as in some
ways you know a good thing it's it's a
basic human instinct desire drive and
what is sexuality
really about it's about um you know
putting things together and building
something greater
and about you know experiencing pleasure
and imposing yourself on the other and
maybe the other imposes on you you know
you can go into all these different
themes there's certainly a lot of
movement going on a lot of vitality
being expressed
and you can hear that listening to
wagner's music and then if you like went
to the spectacle there's all this stuff
going on
and people would like swoon
people get
excited sexually
you know erotically about this sort of
stuff so for wagner to be about chastity
later on what's going on with that
you could ask this about really any any
sort of artist
he says
what is the meaning of this change of
sense this radical reversal wagner
leaped over into his
opposite so he says
here if we're disposed to pause for a
moment at this question we're reminded
of what was perhaps the finest strongest
happiest most courageous
period of wagner's wife the period
during which he was deeply concerned
with an idea and what was that idea the
idea of luther's wedding
he says who knows upon what chance
events it depended that instead of this
wedding music
we possess today the meistersinger
luther's wedding why would that be
particularly important
he says nature says
there is no necessary antithesis between
chastity and sensuality every good
marriage every genuine love affair
transcends this antithesis
wagner would have done well i think to
have brought this pleasant fact
home once more to his germans by means
of a bold and beautiful luther comedy
for there have always been and still are
many slanderers of sensualities among
the germans and perhaps luther performed
no greater service than to have had the
courage of his sensuality in those days
it was called delicately enough
evangelical freedom and you know it's
interesting because you know nietzsche
is of course a great anti-christian but
he sees in luther and he sees in
not just you know reacting against rome
in a certain respect that's that's less
important
is that luther married
it's that luther was
a person who as morbid as he was and as
guilty and and all these other things
as he was luther was somebody who
actually understood
the christian notion of the goodness of
created being
not just ideals
not just the highest parts of created
being like our reason
but other parts as well
now they have to be you know kept within
limits so luther wasn't saying go out
and sleep with whoever you want but
luther went out and got married
why because marriage is a good because
sexuality is a good
for for somebody like like luther
a damaged good to be sure one that can
lead us into lots of different problems
but a good
so nietzsche says you know wagner would
have done better to stick with that
theme
so what's going on
you know
why did luther
um
not with luther why did
why did wagner turn against sensuality
so he says
we have to ask this other question what
is that male
country or what that male
country simpleton was to him the poor
devil and nature boy parseval but whom
he finally made into a catholic by such
capticious means
was this parcel meant seriously percival
was this this boy who grows out out in
the woods and eventually becomes a
knight he's part of this the king arthur
uh series and in in certain stories he
actually attains the grail
in others it's galahad who attains it um
but percival is kind of a simpleton
uh stupid guy
rude uh and also doesn't know what you
know what to do with with things or
women or you know anything really
so he says
is wagner's parcel of secret laughter of
superiority out of himself the triumph
of his ultimate artist freedom and his
transcendence one could wish that it
were
for what would a seriously intended
participle be
or must one really see in him the
product of an insane hatred of knowledge
spirit and sensuality
a curse on the senses and the spirit in
a single breath of hatred an apostasy in
return to morbid christian and
obscurantist ideals and ultimately a
self-negation a self-cancellation on the
part of an artist who had hitherto aimed
with all the power of his will at the
reverse at the highest spiritualization
and centralization of art so what is you
know what does the aesthetic ideal bring
to art it undoes it
he says one must recall how
enthusiastically wagner at one time
followed in the footsteps of the
philosopher feuerbach feuerbach was all
for bach was a
left hegelian which means a radical
hegelian and he was a materialist so he
said all this stuff that hegel is doing
over here we actually have to sort of
turn it on its head he was sort of
prefiguring marx in a certain way
and he said
that um our worship
really ought to be directed not at god
but at humanity and we ought to try to
cultivate everything that there is in
humanity all the potential
and enjoy life as much as we can
so
wagner abandons that
so he says um
the poet and creator of parcel could no
more be spared a deep thorough even
frightful identification with and
dissenting medieval soul conflicts a
hostile separation from all spiritual
height severity and discipline a kind of
intellectual perversity
then can a pregnant woman be spared the
repellent and bizarre aspects of
pregnancy
um
kind of an interesting thing to say
about this typical nietzsche rhetoric
too by the way
and
so he draws us to a close talking about
the artists sort of you know imposing
their their will
um
and that participle is really
where things are are going with
with uh at least with wagner he abandons
the call of true art for nietzsche
so now let's try again
this section 5 says what then is the
meaning of ascetic ideals
in the case of the artist
nothing whatsoever
it's a dead end for the artist
it says let's eliminate them
what about the philosophers
he says
we've arrived at a more serious question
he's going to use schopenhauer as an
example for this what does it mean when
a genuine philosopher pays homage to the
ascetic ideal
a genuinely independent spirit like
schopenhauer a man and knight of steely
eye who had the courage to be himself
who knew how to stand alone without
first waiting for heralds and signs from
above
so you know schopenhauer in a certain
respect is is embodying what nietzsche
is about in advocating his sort of form
of morality schopenhauer is asserting
himself he sets himself you know some
great opponents to fight against he
hates hegel there's a whole story there
that i'm not going to go into but he
establishes hegel and hegel's
interpretation of idealism as the enemy
fights against it constantly he's kind
of a heroic figure in certain respects
well schopenhauer was interested in art
and he says let's here consider straight
away the remarkable and for many kinds
of men even fascinating attitude
schopenhauer adopted towards art
schopenhauer
treated art as something
to be a spectator of to be a consumer of
and why
because art and aesthetic
speculation theory
you know just
contemplation
not active not actively in being
involved in it not created
creating it
but
taking it in
gave you
an answer or at least a response
to not only the problem with the
experience of suffering
aesthetic contemplation allowed you to
get away from yourself
to be able to detach
from who you were and how you felt and
what you were undergoing and your
history and to be absorbed in the object
that you were paying attention to
wagner
was actually creating art that could
could perform that task you might say so
he says
schopenhauer made use of the conscient
version of the aesthetic problem
although he didn't view it with
conscience
kant thought that he was honoring art
when among the predicates of beauty he
emphasized and gave prominence to those
which established the honor of knowledge
impersonality and universality i'm going
to put that on the board because that's
key to the ascetic ideal for the
philosopher
impersonality
universality
and i'm going to put another term that
we often associate with these
objectivities
and
attachment
this is the aesthetic ideal for the
philosopher
nietzsche starts out talking about this
in terms of schopenhauer moving from
wagner to schopenhauer and then talking
about kant
so it's about aesthetics right about art
about consumption of beauty
apprehension and beauty
but really this applies to everything
that we're talking about when we are
thinking about philosophy in the
traditional sense at least as nietzsche
understood it and at least as
many people have understood philosophy
that if you arrive at philosophical
truth it's going to be something
impersonal
something that doesn't actually depend
on who i am or what my
relationship with that truth is
it's going to be universal
namely it's open to everybody
who can apprehend it
it applies everywhere at all times
it's not particularized
objectivity
there's a lack of bias
a
absence of the idols you know to use
bacon's notion of that term the things
that intervene and get between us
actually grasping things as they are
and it involves detachment we take
ourselves out of the picture
so that a certain part of ourselves or
an idealized version of ourself can see
things the way they truly are can
appreciate things for how they really
are
so
kant and schopenhauer made
art into something for the spectator
like he says
kant like all philosophers instead of
envisaging the aesthetic problem from
the point of view of the artist the
creator
the one who's actually doing something
the one who's involved in action
considered art in the beautiful purely
from that of the spectator or we would
say the consumer
and unconsciously
introduce the spectator into the concept
beautiful
it would not have been so bad nietzsche
says that the spectator had at least
been sufficiently familiar to the
philosophers of beauty namely as a great
personal
right not impersonal personal fact and
experience as an abundance of vivid
authentic experiences desires surprises
and delights in the realm of the
beautiful
but i fear that the reverse has been
always the case
philosophers
and this is actually true if i consider
many of my colleagues i don't
associate philosophers with the
really fun sensual
life enjoying uh
people
there are some who are like that
i might actually be one of them to
summon at some degree
but many philosophers many academics
many scholars many scientists many
people like that really are kind of
not just nerdy
but
detached from the life that's out there
why is that
you know they in some respects they
don't have a large enough wealth of
experiences
to be able to talk about some of the
things that they do to know the value of
some of the things that they they want
to think about
i'm going to skip over some of the
discussion of schopenhauer and now come
back to
this discussion that he goes in with
with uh
what schopenhauer is actually
doing
so he says as long as there are
philosophers on earth and wherever there
have been philosophers from india to
england to take the polls of
philosophical endowment there
unquestionably exists a peculiar
philosopher's irritation act and rancor
against sensuality
so philosophy for nietzsche always
involves a kind of pulling back away
from our instincts
our drives our animal nature
our sensuality schopenhauer is merely
its most eloquent and if one has ears
for this most ravishing and delightful
expression
so nietzsche is trying to do something
quite the opposite he's trying to make
philosophy into something that actually
would be sensual
would be
deeply involved with the life of the
instincts the affects
he says there also exists a peculiar
philosopher's prejudice and affection
both in favor of the whole aesthetic
ideal so the ascetic ideals involved one
should not overlook that
both to repeat pertain to the type if
both are lacking in a philosopher
so what what are these
the ascetic ideal
and a prejudice against
um
sensuality a rancor against it
then this person is only a so-called
philosopher
he says what does that mean
what is the significance of this this
kind of
ascentiousness of philosophers
he says this fact has to be interpreted
in itself it just stands there so he
says every animal
also the philosophical animal
instinctively strives for an optimum of
favorable conditions under which it can
expend its strength and achieve its
maximal feeling of power this is part of
having the will to power so you know
play for example i'm going to sort of
deviate from nietzsche's text here just
to give some examples play
is
a way in which we arrange things in our
environment and with our fellow beings
so that we can actually expend power and
feel power on things
and we we play with the things that we
actually are good at don't we that's
that's what is fun
so he says every animal of abhors just
as instinctively and with a subtlety of
discernment that is higher than all
reason
every kind of intrusion or hindrance
that obstructs or could obstruct this
path to the optimum
and he says something very important
here it says i'm not talking about the
path to happiness
but its path to power
to action to the most powerful activity
and in most cases actually to
unhappiness within every animal there is
a drive to do what it is that that
animal is good at and and to avoid the
things that it's it's not good at the
things that that constitute obstacles
hindrances impediments
this is why kids want to work on the
things that they're already good at and
we have to actually force them to do
things that they're not good at because
it's a natural animal thing for him so
he says the philosopher of [ __ ]
marriage
together with that which might persuade
to it marriage being a hindrance and
calamity on his path to the optimum
this is an interesting example isn't it
what great philosopher hitherto has been
married
heraclitus didn't get married
plato descartes spinoza leiden it's kant
schopenhauer they were not one cannot
even imagine them married
so what does this mean
um we have to read more into this we
cannot imagine them doing two basic
things
that go along with marriage in the
traditional sense
one is having sex
living the life of desire
with somebody else who you want to have
sex with
perhaps even generate offspring who then
you have to raise
and care about
be not only having sex though having
affection back and forth
growing with that person
what else what else is involved in in
marriage
having a household
managing your affairs
trying to grow your place
you know who actually wouldn't fit this
bill all that well
aristotle
aristotle had a household he actually
you know
gave advice on how to run households in
the economics which i know some scholars
think is not aristotle's work but it's
pretty aristotelian
there have been married philosophers
nietzsche would say
they are actually deviating from the
ideal of the philosopher by doing so
it says they were not one cannot even
imagine them married a married
philosopher belongs in comedy and as for
that exception socrates
the malicious socrates it would seem
married ironically just to demonstrate
this proposition what does he mean by
that well you know
socrates wife uh was supposed to be this
real hard to get along with person they
call her shrew right
and
there's a story i don't know this is
true or not but there's a story that
socrates married her
precisely because he figured if i can
get along with her
i can get along with anybody so i'm
going to marry her just it's sort of
like you know doing exercise passive
exercise where you put ankle weights on
hey if you walk around with ankle
weights all the time then you take those
ankle weights off it feels like you're
you're skipping on air so socrates
treated marriage in that way that's
that's a very ascetic understanding of
marriage isn't it
so he says every philosopher would speak
of as buddha did when he was told the
birth of a son
rahul has been born to me a fetter has
been forged from me and rahul means a
little demon so there's this turn
against life
involved in living the life of a
philosopher so he says what then is the
meaning of the ascetic ideal in the case
of a philosopher
my answer is you'll have guessed it long
ago the philosopher sees in it an
optimum condition
for the highest and boldest spirituality
and smiles he does not deny existence he
rather affirms
his existence
and only his existence and this perhaps
to the point where he's not far from
harboring the impious wish
perry
mundus fiat philosopher
philosophus
namely
let the world
fall into to ruin let the world be
destroyed
but let there be philosophy let there be
a philosopher
let me be
so
the aesthetic ideal in the case of a
philosopher
is actually expressing a particular form
of the will to power
a will to dominate a will to control a
will to
make things center around you a will to
make what it is that you're good at
what everything else should should be
focused upon
you know is this a fair characterization
of philosophers
um
i don't know
interact with a few uh present day
modern philosophers and see whether you
think that really is the case
i'd say interact with plenty of other
academics and you might find some who
are like that
so he says they're not unbiased
witnesses and judges of the value of the
ascetic ideal this is another important
point this is in section eight these
philosophers they think of themselves
what is this saint to them they think of
what they can least do without freedom
from compulsion disturbance noise from
tasks duties worries clear heads the
dance leap and flight of ideas good air
thin clear open dry like the air of the
heights through which all animal being
becomes more spiritual and acquires
wings repose in all cellular regions all
dogs nicely chained up no barking of
hostility and shaggy-haired rancor no
gnawing worm of injured ambition
undemanding and obedient intestines
right even your guts are serving you
busy as windmills but silent
but distant the heart remote beyond
heavy with future posthumous
all in all he says
they think of the ascetic ideal as the
cheerful asceticism of an animal become
fledged and divine floating above life
rather in repose so to do philosophy
requires that our animal
nature and all those other things that
we're surrounded by
shut the hell up
it's a sort of naysaying a subordination
of everything philosophy at least in the
sense that he's talking about here
insofar as it's inhabited by the ascetic
ideal
is a kind of turning against the rest of
reality in the world so that one part of
reality the philosopher and what it is
the philosopher's thinking about can
become the only
meaningful
realities
now he says something really interesting
here and a transition is taking place
that's going to move us to the priest
the three great slogans of the ascetic
ideal are familiar poverty humility
chastity these are the monastic
ideals
the ones running throughout
most monastic orders not just in in
christianity too but also in islam you
know with the sufis in buddhism with all
the different orders of monks
poverty humility chastity
why
because these things that's part of the
ascetic ideal these things are supposed
to be freeing up the human being
to turn themselves away from all those
other things they would be bothered with
so that they can focus on the one good
the one thing necessary that they want
to
choose that they will
to choose the will
again exercising itself as the will to
power towards this object
so he says now take a look at the lives
of all the great fruitful and non-full
spirits you will always encounter
all three to a certain degree
not it goes without saying as though
these constituted their virtues
but the most appropriate natural
conditions of their best existence their
fairest fruitfulness it's quite possible
that they're dominating spirituality at
first to put a check on unrestrained and
irritable pride or wanting such
sensuality or that it perhaps had a hard
job to maintain its will to the desert
against a love of luxury and refinement
or an excessive liberality of heart and
hand
but it did
precisely because it was a dominating
instinct whose demands prevailed against
those of all the other instincts
he continues to do it if it did not do
it if it would not dominate there is
less nothing of virtue in this there's
the will to power in this
humility
poverty chastity
these have to be participated in to some
extent to get things done to change what
one is to be able to
apply oneself to to other things
so
he's going to go on and talk a little
bit more about the philosopher
and he says
a philosopher may be recognized by the
fact that he avoids three glittering and
loud things three distractions what are
they
fame
princes and women
glory
reputation celebrity being somebody in
the world
princes
political power
might even monetary power perhaps in our
our society and women which is not to
say that they do not come to him
he shuns light that is too bright
that is why he shuns his age in its day
as for humility he endures a certain
dependence and eclipse as he endures the
darkness he is afraid of being
distracted by lightning
he moves away from things that can keep
him from say contemplating the good or
investigating nature or whatever it is
that the philosopher is working on
working upon his own desires if he's
epictetus and stowing right
he talks also about the chastity of
philosophers and he says something
really interesting here this type of
spirit clearly has its fruitfulness
somewhere other than in children
perhaps it also is the survival of its
name elsewhere it's little immortality
are philosophers attempting to be
immortal to bring forth spiritual
children you might say
so he goes on as in section 9 he says we
have seen how a certain asceticism a
severe and cheerful continence with the
best will
belongs to the most favorable conditions
of supreme spirituality and is also
among its most natural consequences
it need be no matter for surprise the
philosophers have always discussed the
ascetic ideal with a certain fondness
if you want to do philosophy
you have to do some of this to some
degree
philosophers will generally place
something above the instincts above the
bodily
desires
above the things going around
going on around them the affairs of the
day so he says philosophy began as all
good things begin
for a long time it lacked the courage
for itself it was always looking around
to see if someone would come and help it
it was afraid of all who looked at it
drop a list of the various propensities
and virtues of the philosopher what are
they
well
these are interesting his bent to doubt
nietzsche says
that sort of skeptical attitude right
is bent to analyze
his bent to deny to suspend judgment you
can see this in socrates already
right
has been to investigate seek dare has
been to compare and balance
his will to neutrality and objectivity
his will to every cena era at studio
without anger without fury
and without desire without zeal
and he goes on and says
it's to repeat no different with all the
good things of which we're proud today
measured even by the standards of the
ancient greeks our entire modern way of
life
insofar as it's not weakness but power
and consciousness of power has the
appearance of sheer hubris and
godlessness
for the longest time it was precisely
the opposite of those that we we would
have valued
and he talks about um
our will to power as extended into to
nature
i'm going to go on now and and we get to
um talk about
we're going to move from the philosopher
backwards in time to the priest he says
the earliest race of contemplative men
is in section 10.
they had to live
under a certain evaluation
what was that valuation they were
opposed to the warriors now we get back
to the priests and this is where we're
actually going to be drawing to a close
they
were under an oppression evaluation
they kind of look like the herd to the
to the warriors what are you doing among
us if you're not actually a fighting guy
they might say
reading those books
studying that stuff what's that all
about
you're kind of you know
kind of suspicious
maybe you're one of the
bad he says contemplation first thought
appeared on earth in disguise an
ambiguous form with an evil heart and
often an anxious head there is no doubt
of that the inactive brooding unwar-like
element in the instincts of the
contemplative man long surrounded them
with a profound mistrustfulness
so the priest
is contemplative
also mistrustful
they have to exert themselves against
the warrior and he says
the earliest philosophers knew how to
endow their existence and appearance of
the meaning of basis and background
through which others might come to fear
them
more closely considered they did so from
an even more fundamental need so as to
fear and reverence themselves
it was trustful
also
producing fear or we might say
controlling
the ascetic ideal
that the philosophers and also the
priests who are the first philosophers
have is a matter of control not only
control of oneself so that one can
realize one's good but also control over
those people who are otherwise going to
push me down it's a way in which the
priest and the warrior can struggle with
each other and the priests can find a
weapon
that the warrior doesn't have and
subjugate them because otherwise the
warriors are going to push them down
and nietzsche gives you know some
examples here
um
he talks about the the philosopher's
pose the ascetic priest and he says has
all this really altered has that many
colored and dangerous wind creature
really been unfettered at last and
released into the light thanks to a
sunnier warmer brighter world
is there sufficient pride daring courage
self-confidence available today
sufficient will of the spirit will to
responsibility freedom of will for the
philosopher to be henceforth possible on
earth for it no longer to be about
control or is it always about
one-upping
the powerful one-upping those who
actually
have the money
have the access have the connections
get to hold the big parties get to
decide who does what get to fight those
who laugh at one the philosopher the
priest they're in a certain way
the ones who are on the outs and use
their knowledge use their capacities use
their ability to actually inspire fear
dread
perhaps even you know guilt bad
conscience in the others
the hot the ones who are higher the ones
who are lower to take control
can we get beyond that
that's what he's asking at that point
so i'm going to leave off here
because now we're actually getting to
the section where he's discussing what's
going on between the priest and the herd
in in detail and i'm going to reserve
that for the next section we'll talk
there about the priest
then we'll talk about
what replaces the priest but actually
does the same thing as the priest going
all the way down to the present